بَيْنَ الحَدِيقَةْ المُزْهِرَةْ ...طَارَتْ فَرَاشَةْ سَاحِرَةْ
رَقِيقَةٌ وَالأَجْنِحَةْ.. بِكُلِّ لَوْنٍ زَاهِيَةْ
بِكُلِّ لَوْنٍ زَاخِرَةْ
بَيْنَ الزُهُورِ لَمَحْتُهَا.. وَبَيْنَ أَنْسَامِ الهَوَا
وَعَجِبْتُ مَنْ أَلْوَانِهَا ...وَبِدَهْشَةٍ قَلْبِي ارْتَوَىْ
فَسَأَلْتَهَا هَلْ تَلْعَبِي ...يَا رَائِعَةْ مَا أَجْمَلَكْ
قَالَتْ أَتَيْت لِمَلْعَبِي... مَهْمَا فَعَلْت سَأَغْلِبُكْ
فَرَدَتْ جَنَاحَيْهَا البَهِيَّةُ ...في هُدُوءٍ رَفْرَفَتْ
وَبَيْنَ أَزْهَارٍ نَدِيَّةْ .... الجَمِيلَةُ اخْتَفَتْ
وَبَدَأْتُ أَبْحَثُ بِالحُقُولِ...وَبَيْنَ أَفْنَانَ الشَّجَرْ
أَلُفُّ في عَجَبٍ أَدُورْ.... بِالرَوْضِ أُمْعِنُ النَظَرْ
وَفَجْأَةً بَيْنَ الزُّهُورِ......اهْتَزَّ طَرْفُ جَنَاحِهَا
طَارَتْ بِضِحْكَتِهَا تَدُورْ.... مِنِّى تَخَفَّتْ بَيْنَهَا
ضَحِكَتْ وَقَالَتْ مَنْ يَفُوزْ...الآَنَ قُلْ لِى ياَ صَدِيقْ
مَنْ كَانَ مَوْهِبَةً يَحُوزْ... حَتَّى وَلَوْ مِثْلِى رَقِيقْ